un poco suspenso en esta ceremonia de
entrega de los premios de este festival
de cannes número 74 a los pocos minutos
de comenzado el espectáculo el
presidente del jurado el estadounidense
spies le dio a conocer por el nombre de
la ganadora de la palma de oro la
película francesa titán de la directora
julia du corno pese a ello hubo sorpresa
ya que la película no estaba entre las
favoritas más si escuchaba el nombre de
drive my car la película japonesa de
hecho se llevó el premio de mejor guión
al salir de agradecer juliá do corno de
37 años la segunda mujer en ganar la
palma de oro de cannes agradeció al
jurado que le permitiera mostrar sus
monstruos y que valorase un cine que no
entre quizás en los esquemas más
tradicionales ella dijo mi película no
es perfecta quizás es incluso para
algunos horrorosa lo dijo en referencia
a las reacciones que hubo durante las
proyecciones mucha gente sufrió de
crisis de angustia salió antes del final
de la película de las proyecciones o con
malestares debido a lo fuerte de las
imágenes de una película de cine cores
sino otros premios a destacar el gran
premio que fue compartido entre la
película memoria una película tailandesa
pero filmada íntegramente en colombia y
la
de compartimiento número 6 y los premios
para mejor actriz se lo llevó la noruega
renate range por la peor persona del
mundo así se llama la película en
español y el premio para la
interpretación masculina fue para caleb
landry por la película australiana
nitram que está basada en una matanza
colectiva ocurrida en 1996 en australia